i cannot wait to see this human let's
get him right on out here and not hold
back keanu reeves where are you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yes yes
i mean i was thinking about by the way
did you know
that it is literally like almost to the
day the 35th anniversary of that
obscure masterpiece babes in toyland
sometimes obscurity's good but there was
a there was a good heart in that piece
we had so much fun making it it was
crazy and richard mulligan jill scholar
pat marita googie grass i'm just looking
back at
you know from 1986 until now we have
both had the privilege
and fortune to keep going yeah and what
a gift and a blessing that is
yeah
you're someone i think of too as being
so incredibly gracious about it
and i definitely feel like i would look
around and see the behaviors of the
people that i wanted to be like one day
and they were always the kind humble
gracious hard-working
you know lovely examples
yeah yeah you are so that i don't know
that's kind of you to say that
i mean i love what i do right i mean i'm
yeah i love acting i like rolling up the
sleeves i like going to work and you
know it is what it is man we ain't you
know
we ain't doctors even lives you know
but we do we can change lives we can't
help you know can i take it back to a
memory that i have with you
i was at this club and it was my 16th
birthday and you came in
this is the memory i have of it if you
have anything to add or change please
let me know and you walked in
and you grabbed my hand
and you took me outside
and you put me on your motorcycle oh my
and we drove at the warp speed of my
life
we went and you took me on the ride of
my life and i was so free i was such a
free human being
and it was just this moment where i just
remember loving life
and being so happy
and i hold it so dear because the older
we get the harder it is to get to that
feeling yeah
yeah
yeah
um i wonder where we're at took you
where was which where where's clover
maria i believe it was on third street
in los angeles okay and
and then i think we definitely took off
down third and then we drove around for
a while and then we went back and i went
back in and i don't remember if you came
in or not i literally walked back into
the party
like skipping
like
i mean
i didn't even think of it as a sweet 16
but i i'm now realizing it you can't
have a better sweet 16 than
being put on your motorcycle and having
the moment where you understand what
freedom is
wow if we were on third i must okay
[Laughter]
oh wow we we probably went fast so yeah
so fast
like irresponsibly fast yeah yeah if we
were on third at night yeah we could get
on it um yeah and we did yeah right on
uh yeah cause riding your bike is is
thrilling and it is there is a freedom
to it and back in those yes beautiful
days
when was the moment that you felt
free if i was to say that is my moment
that i hearken to
feeling so free do you have one
um
yeah i've got a few
yeah
but uh
since we're here and there's a film i'll
talk about uh acting
as a young kid i decided or you know
my mom says i declare i want to be an
actor
when i was 15.
and
why would that person ask or say that
and i and i recall when
acting you know in school or doing
shakespeare
um
you know playing mercutio
that sense of being free was play
like it was
fun it was fun
make believe but reality
you know connection
um
a group collaboration families you know
get into that and then and also the
imagination it's private it's public
it's together
it's shared
um you commune you tell a story i love
stories
you know stories you know you're talking
about you know being an example you know
stories help us contextualize the world
help us see it
you know um for the things that we don't
know things that we can imagine get
advice whatever all those kinds of
communications and
um i love that about it but it was fun
you know somehow being in the moment i
love when what happens after someone
says action
you know that's the director or the
first ad sometimes will say
action
and then we begin and we're in the
moment
you know we might have prepared a lot we
have our past and our history and what
we're trying to do in the story we're
trying to tell but that moment of action
or let's begin
that's like it's fun
it's fun
so i'm really grateful to be able to um
um
earn a living
and have a career
you know try and have a career
you know something that i love and and
in a simple thing just to have fun
[Applause]
[Music]